- All right, here we go,
this is the Rubin Report.
I'm still Dave Rubin and I have a feeling
that YouTube may not be
thrilled with this episode,
so even more reason to
subscribe and click that bell
so that you actually get
notified when the clips come out.
And joining me today is the
VP of the Trump Organization
and the author of the new book, Triggered.
Donald Trump, Jr., welcome
to The Rubin Report.
- Good to be with you, buddy.
- All right, here we go, man.
I'm 50-50 on whether this
stream is going to be up
by the time I finish this
very sentence right now.
What do you think?
- It's sort of a win either way, right?
If they censor you we can blow it up
and make it go everywhere
then other people will watch.
But it's a shame that we even have to have
that conversation.
- It's sort of ridiculous,
we're gonna get to that.
And that actually has a lot to
do with what you write about
in the book here, about
all the tech censorship
and all that stuff.
But before we do any of that,
I don't know if you
remember but a couple days
you were on The View,
that View program on ABC.
- I don't remember that.
No one's mentioned that to me since.
- Do you remember that?
So there were so many things that happened
in that interview that I was like holy cow
this is everything that
I talk about all at once.
So let's just try to hit a
couple things in a row here.
First off, the way the
interview started where Whoopi,
who I used to really like Whoopi.
I think she used to be a decent liberal
and now she kind of gone off
the progressive deep end.
She couldn't even say
your name in the intro.
She literally refused to say your name.
What does that feel like when you sit down
and you know you're in enemy territory?
And then the way they treat you
before anything has happened?
- Well listen, it obviously
shows just how disingenuous
the whole thing is first
and foremost, right?
I mean they invite you on
to talk about your book.
Did you hear a question?
I did three segments.
I'm not a baby, like I
get I'm gonna get hit.
I get that in that case there's not even
a conservative on my
side, given the history.
- Meghan's there, but she's not really.
- Abby Huntsman's sort of, what are you?
There's not a lot of personality there
for that kind of stuff.
So I get it, I get that I'm
going into the lion's den.
But come on, they're gonna
lecture me about civility?
But you have me on for
a pretense, the book.
You don't ask me a single
question about the book
and you refuse to even
mention my last name?
This is going wrong real
fast, but that's okay.
- So she basically said
the son of the President.
Then she kind of choked out DJT.
- Don, Jr., I think or
Donald, Junior, she said.
But she never said Trump.
I'm like it's okay, I guess people know.
But what's the pur--, what does it serve?
- Yeah, but it does set a certain tone
that's been consistent.
I mean Rand Paul was on
there a couple weeks ago
and the way that they were treating him.
But then a few things happened in a row
that I thought were pretty interesting.
So you started getting
hit and you apparently
had done a little research,
'cause you turned the question
around and said to Joy,
you know Joy, you've been in Blackface.
And now Joy has been in Blackface,
she has admitted it on The View.
She immediately says she hasn't.
Whoopi then said, well I'm a Black woman
and I know what Blackface is.
- And Whoopi, and you
supported Roman Polanski,
a child rapist.
- It's not rape rape,
that's what she said.
- You know, yeah you're right.
Sodomy of a 13, 14-year
old girl under Quaaludes,
you're right that's not rape, Whoopi.
If that's not rape I don't know what is.
Now you seeing by the way,
literally the day after it broke
some other woman accused him.
So is that one rape rape?
I just wanna make sure we're clear.
- But what do you make of
the idea that they never
get these things turned on them?
That's what was so shocking
to me, nobody does it
even though we all know it.
- Correct, and it was
funny 'cause I see that.
I mean in the last couple days
doing these book signings.
Even these guys will
come to the book signing.
They'll be like I love
what you did on The View.
I'm like, what were you
doing watching The View?
They're like uh, uh.
(laughing)
It was sort of funny turning that around.
But I think what it is honestly, Dave,
so many people are used
to going on those shows.
They have big viewerships,
they have big following.
They want to get invited back.
They're there to pitch
something, as was I.
I mean I didn't just go on there for fun.
They're there to pitch something
so they're so desperate
about wanting to be invited
back that even though
it was their 5,000th episode,
I don't think anyone's
ever pushed back on them.
They can sort of say
it's The View, not views.
There's one view and if you don't have it
they're gonna go after you.
So I guess I just sort
of took their script on
and people were like well how
much did you prep for this?
I didn't prep for that.
I literally, like you know what?
Let me have something in my back pocket.
If we can have a civil
discourse that's great.
If we can talk about it and again,
understanding that this can be done.
- So truly it was not your
intention to flip it on them?
- No, I sort of held off, but
it was like they went at me
so hard I figured hey, if
I'm on for three segments,
hey we'll talk a little bit
and then they'll get rough.
But just the opening
salvo's just aggressive.
Even the conservatives
sort of come at you.
So I was like okay, game on, I can play.
So I didn't prep but I went on Google.
I was like stupidest things
ever said on The View.
This was not a well-researched
counterattack measure.
But it was good to have
something in my back pocket
that shows a lot of that hypocrisy.
- What does that tell you more broadly
about the media though,
that they usually know
they can sort of say
whatever they want?
And I don't mean just The View hosts.
But basically sort of all the lefty media
can say whatever they want.
You guys just sort of
take the hits usually.
And then the media then will
cover their tracks after.
That's sort of the game that I think
a lot of this book is about.
- Most people won't even go.
Most people are afraid
of the confrontation
on a live screen and stuff like that.
They're concerned.
The different between me and so many pe--,
like I don't care what the media says.
Some of the guys that I
spend a lot of time with
now in politics and stuff,
they've literally have
reporters call like what is it?
Don, he just doesn't seem
to mind when we attack?
Like because I don't, it
means absolutely nothing.
- Where do you think that
comes, do you think that's
directly from your dad?
- Listen, I've been used to it.
I think there's a genetic component.
I sort of joke in the book.
I say it took us probably
41 years to realize
we were much more like each other
than you would have
thought with my hobbies,
the outdoors, the this.
My sleeping on couches in the
Midwest, that's not his thing.
He doesn't understand that.
So I think if anyone would have asked us
prior to sort of the
viciousness of politics
they would have been like
Don's the one that's probably
least likely.
Now it was like well they
kind of fight the same way.
You've backed us in a corner,
you attack us for three
years mercilessly, we fight.
And you know, I guess
that's the difference.
It just doesn't bother me that much.
So I don't really care what
other people think of me.
It's never been something
that's phased me that much.
So I'll get my part out and
whatever they say, they say.
I don't freak out if I get bad press.
I get bad press every day.
Anything I do and say
can be used against me.
This is relevant because
it's literally today,
Veteran's Day.
In the book I wrote, there's
a chapter about sort of
the victory.
And I say after two years of
sort of that just fighting
during the campaign, when
we won on election night
I was not at all excited about it.
It wasn't like we won a
hockey game and it's like yes,
two hours of--.
- [Dave] Yeah, you're more like oh shit.
- It was so vicious.
The ups and downs, the ebbs
and flows, they're so intense
it wears you down, it beats you down.
So when we won and they're like we got it,
I'm pacing around like a caged animal.
Like no no no, they're gonna do something.
They're gonna take what
Hillary said Trump supporters
were gonna do, they're
gonna do exactly that.
Turned out I was right.
Meaning they were gonna try to contend.
They were gonna protest in the streets.
That's what she's saying
Trump supporters are gonna do.
- They're not gonna accept the results.
- 100%, so I was there like no no no.
I figured this game out now.
They are gonna do something.
So when John Podesta got
on stage and was like well,
I was happier about that
even though it meant
we were still fighting and it wasn't over,
than I was that we had won which
is a pretty warped reality.
But again, two years of--
- What was that night like though?
Because Hillary didn't concede that night.
- Well she did, she did
later on that night.
- Well she did and sort of didn't.
- Yeah, it was sort of a
wishy-washy concession.
Then it was like let's see
if we can pull some recounts.
Turns out that we actually got
more votes in the recounts.
So I wasn't at all psyched.
It didn't hit me yet what
we had won and accomplished.
So I write a chapter in the
book saying when it hit me
was literally like
two-and-a-half months later.
And it was rolling into Arlington
for the wreath-laying ceremony.
And I was like I'm not an
overly-emotional kind of guy.
Like I said I can kind of
compartmentalize the hate
and just move on.
But dude, it hit me pretty hard.
We're rolling into Arlington
and you see the gravity
of the responsibility
that is what my father
has to do right now.
I was so happy then.
It all hit me then because
he's the guy in charge.
I know he's gonna be such a good leader.
I know he's going to get
out of these endless wars.
And you're seeing it and
some guy in the left wing
tries, takes some of it.
He compared his sacrifices.
Everything, all the B.S.
that we've been going through
100% worth it because he's the leader now
that we need.
And they tried to make it
seem as though like I was
obviously saying that my
sacrifices as a business,
as a person over a campaign was the same
as the death of Americans.
I was like honestly I can't even engage
because they'll try to build.
But no reasonable person
outside of Left Wing
and Vanity Fair and these loser
pubs that will try to take
anything you say and dunk on you,
no reasonable human being of the thousands
that have reached out to
me that love the book,
not one has even thought
that what they're saying
I must have meant was what I meant.
I don't think any reasonable person would.
But that's what they will
do and that's the sickness
that is really out there in the media.
- In a weird way, though, do
you guys kind of need that now?
You know what I mean?
It's sort of become this
self-fulfilling prophesy.
It's like the media is awful.
Everyone watching this knows that.
They keep doubling down on lies and racist
and homophobe and all that nonsense.
And we'll get to all that.
- I wasn't talking with
you before we ever got
into politics, right?
- Okay so let's just do that real quick.
I was going to save it for
later but about eight years ago
you did my Sirius XM show.
It was on the OutQ gay channel.
I didn't want to be on the gay channel.
But they were like you're gay.
- You've gotta start somewhere,
Dave, congratulations.
- Okay so I guess I did start somewhere.
But it was separate but
equal, you know what I mean?
You have an equal radio channel
but it's the gay channel.
But anyway, I got in touch with you,
you came on the show.
And at this time again eight years ago
you were for gay marriage,
your dad was not.
This was way before he
was running for president
or anything.
And I asked you about
that and I'm not gonna,
you can repeat what you
said, basically if you want.
- I probably said something to the effect
of you know what?
Happy people are productive people.
It doesn't bother me at all.
By the way, I'm the same way
frankly with the trans thing.
I spend a chapter on that.
But where I draw the
line is when it's like
okay well now Dave, you can be a woman now
and go compete against women.
You have that MMA fight
or something via Fox.
It was a man MMA fighter, a
male, transitioned to female.
Gets into the first fight as a female.
Breaks the orbital socket of
a female opponent's skull.
I mean, you're a great champion.
Like come on man, stop it.
They're breaking every women's world,
you know, weightlifting
record, every bike--.
So I've finally sort of been like man,
I can be as live and let live as you want.
But there's a line that we've got to draw.
And I sort of feel like
today if you're woke here,
by tomorrow you're alt-right.
It's a never ending goalpost.
I can't keep up, I try to see it.
I want to see the other side.
I want to hear the opinion
at least and make up
my own mind.
But now it's like okay
I can buy into this.
It's like well now do you buy in to this?
It's all over.
I mean they did it, the
example they use in the book
is I talk about Martina Navratilova,
great LGBT activist for 40
years, before it was cool.
She came out, one of the
great female athletes
of all time.
We knew her growing up.
She had a similar story to my mother
escaping Czechoslovakia
and all that stuff.
And I was like she said
basically what I was saying
and the left destroyed her.
The LGBT crowd that she
was an activist for,
she was one of the original leaders of,
destroys her as if 40 years of
being the greatest supporter
in the world for them meant nothing.
So she has to walk it back,
she's owned, she's disgraced.
Three weeks later she has
to obviously come out again
against Trump for something
just because that's the penance
you pay to get back into the woke zone.
And I was like that's weird.
She never had anything
to say about it before.
She grew up with us, obviously.
But that's how insane it's gotten.
So again everyone's like oh you're so--,
I'm like I'm pretty live and let live.
We have to be able to delineate.
And I say it on Twitter and stuff.
And what's funny is if I
put up anything on Twitter
the hate flows.
Honestly, before anyone can
even read the tweet and respond,
40 tweets like you're (growls).
Just insane, but even then
I think I see these guys
like oh man they're saying it.
I can't believe it, I'm actually agreeing
with Donald Trump, Jr. on something.
They're taking it so far
they're even losing themselves.
- Yeah it's so interesting because
what you're basically saying is that
the progressives of tomorrow will hate
the progressives of today.
That's exactly how it works.
- Correct, I mean I say
they like to make fun of it,
but I think it's kind of true.
John F. Kennedy, the leader
of that party for so long,
he'd be alt-right today right?
According to their rules
and their standards.
And that's what it is.
We're not up against the
Democrat party anymore.
They've been taken over by the left.
So when I go around to
the Rust Belt and I talk
to these people I always say this is not
your grandfather's Democrat party.
Oh Don you know, we're voting for your dad
but if my grandfather knew I was voting
for a Republican he'd be
rolling over in his grave.
I go, what would your
grandfather say about today's
Democrat party platform?
- [Dave] Yeah you get
that answer pretty quick.
- The light bulb goes off
and that's when they get it.
The party that was for
working class Americans,
that no longer exists.
Now they're for the ultimate fringe.
The example I think I sort of, you know,
Elizabeth Warren the other day.
Black trans, I don't even know honestly,
I don't even know what all of the--
- Latin X, they're the
backbone of society.
- So I go they are a 1/1024th
of the backbone of society,
like her Native American status.
I'm not saying that
they're not part of it,
but they are not, how about
all our military veterans?
How about teachers?
How about everyone that's
part of productive society?
The backbone is everyone together,
not how far can we take it?
Okay that's America.
I was like everyone's America.
That's the whole point
of this great experiment.
And to go into these identity politics
where we're catering
to the .000002 percent
of the population.
Be like no, that's you America.
It's ridiculous.
- And it's a constant
movement of destruction
because to lift somebody
you've always got to take
somebody down.
So it creates competing interests.
- I'm gonna have to do
a podcast and ask you
because as a gay man,
what are your thoughts
as it relates to sort of
again, outspoken activist
homosexual people getting
owned by the trans movement
and it's not enough after the years
that you guys fought to get
the equality that you have
that people probably
pretend doesn't exist.
- As I told you eight years ago,
all I ever wanted was exact
equality under the law.
That's what we've got.
You can call it now we're equal.
You can call me whatever you
want, you know what I mean?
You could call me a fag right now--
- [Donald] And that's
what it feels like to me.
- It wouldn't mean anything to me.
- Again the further that
you go they actually
don't want equality.
They want more than equality.
Everyone needs some sort
of form of reparations
often times, at least
as it relates to that,
for problems that probably
no one had even heard of
or even knew existed.
So it wasn't like they
were oppressed like some
communities actually were for so long.
I didn't know what trans was
until a few years ago probably.
- Well that's a thing.
They were going to whatever
bathroom they wanted to
and it was fine.
- Nobody cares.
- And your dad even said
what was it, two years ago
your dad said the thing
about if a trans person
comes into Trump Tower
they'll use whatever bath.
- Hey listen, I'm a builder.
I would love to build
one universal bathroom.
We're real estate people.
If I don't have to build
dual bathrooms I can actually
save a whole lot of money.
I wish everyone would share a bathroom.
I think it'd be wonderful.
- All right so let's
shift for just a second
then we're gonna get back
to a lot of this stuff.
The leaker.
Now right now I know that
we're doing this on YouTube.
This is a live stream.
If we name the leaker, even
though the name is out there.
- [Donald] You're out.
- They are most likely
going to shut this stream.
They might shut this stream
anyway just because we're now
talking about it.
But the leaker, it's been
named in a zillion things
on a zillion outlets.
It's already been on television.
Facebook has said it's taking down content
with the leaker's name.
YouTube's been taking down live streams.
They did a big one last
night that they took down.
So I'm just gonna read
you the statement on this
and then we'll talk about it the best way
we kind of can here, right?
So a YouTube spokesperson
said, "Videos mentioning
"the potential whistleblower's
name would also be removed.
"The spokesperson said
that the company would use
"a combination of machine
learning and human review
"to scrub the content."
I'm pretty sure we're getting
both of those right now.
"The removals, the spokesperson added,
"would affect the titles
and descriptions of videos
"as well as the video's actual content."
So look, I don't want this
video to be taken down.
But they're obviously
watching it right now.
The name is out there.
There's a picture of this
person on the White House lawn
the day your dad showed
up at the White House
after the election.
- It's interesting,
I've gotten to be a part
of the outrage cycle.
It's a very fast cycle.
(both men speaking at once)
We've been on here for about 10 minutes.
I'm sure that the cycle
of outrage has changed
and had adapted to something
else since we've been on.
But I was part of the outrage
cycle I guess last week
because I apparently
outed the whistleblower.
- Even though it was
all over the internet.
- I retweeted an article
that literally had his name
in the title of the article.
It was on the Drudge Report.
The View was like who knows
about the Drudge Report?
I go like, I don't know,
it's like the largest
news aggregator anywhere
in the world, probably.
I mean it was on the Drudge
Report four days prior to that.
It was in real clear politics,
so I put it out there.
Donald Trump, Jr., outs.
I still don't know his last name.
I was just retweeting the
article, I could care less.
But I realized pretty quickly
it wasn't so much, Dave,
that they were outraged
that I had outed him,
it's that now the name is
known people can actually
do some research.
- [Dave] So that's what
I want to get to, yeah.
- He's a humble public
servant who's just trying
to do what's right.
No, he's a CIA guy who was Biden's guest
at a state dinner who was
good friends with Brennan,
apparently, who is in the
photograph as you mentioned,
the day my father is President-elect
and going to the White House.
Crying like a little child you
know, in that group picture
where everyone's so morose
and they're all wearing black.
They're in mourning because
it's the end of their world
as we know it with Susan
Rice or whoever else
was in the picture.
They're like yeah, that guy.
He's gonna be super
objective, he's just a humble.
You know this didn't start,
his lawyer doing tweets
in January of 2017 right
after the inauguration.
The coup has started, impeachment is next.
Right along with the
stuff that looks awfully
like really weird child stuff.
There's nothing wrong with these people.
That's the point, they
weren't upset that his name
was out there.
They're upset that it's
another Muller that I get into
so much in the book.
It's the Muller investigation.
When he's an innocent public servant
he's beyond reproach,
he's just a nice guy.
When he's a CIA guy with ties to Biden,
when he's in the photo
crying you see that this
is not an objective, unbiased person.
This is the swamp at its finest.
This is a deep-state guy that
wants to help out his people
and they will do whatever
they can to attack Trump
because Trump is going in
and breaking up their cabal,
their system that they've
built up for so long
that they know and love that
has made all their friends
really rich.
And that's a problem for them.
- So let me ask you a question
as a guy who punches back.
Do you think I'm basically
sort of half-stepping this here
by not saying his name?
I mean I'm tempted to say his name.
- I don't know that that
matters because anyone can go on
right now and just type
it in and figure it out
for themselves.
So I'd rather frankly keep the platform.
But again the whole point of this--
- You don't want me to
ruin my entire career
right this second just to--
- Let's give them a little bit more.
But I mean it's so much a part of the book
which is that social media censorship.
They have decided, like
the mainstream media,
to be the marketing arm
of the Democrat party,
all those leftist policies.
- How do you think they coordinate it?
Something like this where it's so
everything that you just said is correct.
The picture is there,
obviously all the connections
and no one wants anything
bad to happen to this guy.
- No, but they pretend.
Hey I wish they would have shown,
you're endangering his life.
I'm endangering the life of a CIA.
I wish I would have seen one
percent, just one percent,
I don't need it all, of
the same amount of outrage
when my wife opened up an
exploding, white powder envelope
of people that was a Warren volunteer.
None of that stuff comes out.
Like that's at my house, my kids.
That doesn't deserve outrage.
But this guy that's
working in the deep state,
he's a CIA guy, he needs our protection.
It's like give me a break.
Come on, I'm not advocating
for violence of anyone.
But at least balance this
thing out in terms of that.
So it's sort of that
outrage that just shows
exactly what we're up against.
- Do you think your dad
always saw that thing,
like that sort of protection racket
between the Democrats and the media?
It seems like he always kinda.
- No one knew how to play
the media better than him
when he was in his career.
I talk about in the book when we went down
to launch the campaign and it
was I guess June, 16, 2015.
The last thing he said to
us before he walked over
to go to the elevator and
we went down to go watch was
now we find out who our real friends are.
So he knows, he understand the real world.
He understands how it works.
He understands how full of
crap most people really are,
you know what I mean?
Everyone's looking for
an angle and honestly
politics is no different.
If anything it's probably
worse in that effect.
Meaning you're great and
you're useful until you're not.
The thing that is missing
so much is loyalty.
You see it and so he's always known
and we've always known that the
media has been left leaning.
It's just now that they've
given up the pretense
of even objectivity.
I mean you see that.
The Washington Post, the
day after the inauguration,
sorry, 19 minutes after the inauguration.
19 minutes wrote the first article,
The Case for Impeachment.
I mean 19 minutes?
That's about the amount of time Obama took
to get nominated for the
Nobel Peace Prize, right?
That was 11 days, I believe.
But that's the difference, right?
So when people ask what
about the impeachment
that started last week?
I go it didn't start last week.
It started on November 9,
2016, okay the day they knew
he had won.
This is when this thing started.
And you know, again if
you weren't a believer
in the deep state prior
to his election, I get it.
If you aren't now,
you're a freaking idiot.
- Can you describe so
people say deep state
and then Twitter's gonna
explode in conspiracy theories.
You basically mean the
layer that always exists
because that's kind of
what kept the machine going
regardless of the administration.
- Essentially manipulating
the people's choice.
Donald Trump was elected by
the people of this country.
This is the unelected
self-appointed leaders
of this country.
If they disagree with the
president who was elected
to do the things that he
campaigned on well we're just
gonna do that because we know better.
And it's that class, it's
that elite, and honestly
that's always existed.
But I think now that class
is not only just existed
but they've become nefarious.
They are doing whatever
they can to not only
do their little thing, but
subvert the actual will
of the people.
That's where it starts getting scary.
- Do you think your dad was the only guy
that could break this?
Because there's a lot
of metaphors for this.
There's a lot of analogies.
Some people say he was the
icebreaker that was gonna
break it's own.
Are we saying he was just the chess board?
He was the guy who was just
like you're all playing
this fake game.
We're gonna toss it up
and see what happens.
- It's probably a combination of the both.
I think the reality is
if you look at sort of
some of the major examples
of this presidency,
take Cavanaugh.
How long do you think let's
say like a Jeb Bush character
under fire.
Unfounded, ridiculous
allegations about gang rape
magically appear.
How long do you think
Jeb would have lasted
when the media took the
sound bites they wanted.
This definitely happened 100%.
We're never gonna question.
A second, maybe two?
That's where I'd set the
over-under before he folded.
It would have ruined this guy's life.
- It wouldn't have made
it those 19 minutes.
- It wouldn't have made it 19 minutes.
So Donald Trump just isn't
gonna buy into the nonsense.
He isn't just gonna cave
to that kind of pressure.
That's exactly what we need
today because we need to really
reset this whole thing.
So he is the perfect vessel for this.
That's why when people
are like well you know,
it's pretty aggressive, I'm
like we've been under attack
for three years.
I mean I see a lot of
moderate Democrats like
honestly I'm a Democrat but
I wish they'd just let him
do his job.
I mean he's accomplished
things that prior pres--,
Obama, had he gotten the
job numbers where they are,
had he done the things for
the African American community
like prison reform, opportunity zones,
they would have knighted
him emperor for life.
- [Dave] He's doing
this racist thing wrong.
- He's like the worst racist
ever because he's failing
miserably.
I mean if you're gonna fail at something
it's great to fail at being a racist.
But it's such nonsense.
I see that because I see
it from the characters.
Whoopi Goldberg, we used that example.
She can't say his name.
Didn't stop her from showing
up at one of the finales
of The Apprentice and hanging out with us
at the after party five, six
years ago whenever that was.
She was there, she didn't
have a problem with us then.
That was another thing
I could have brought up.
I mean there's just so
many examples of this.
It didn't stop Al Sharpton
from saying all these
complimentary things.
Rev. Jesse Jackson for
saying hey, he gave us space
on a Wall Street building
when we weren't anything.
I have pictures with half
of the resistance at dinner.
- So that's what your dad meant by the
we're gonna find out who our friends are
because he basically had
connections with everybody
in that world.
- He knew he had done so
much and that's the reality.
When Al Sharpton needed a
place to stay in New York,
this is one of the stories in the book,
he literally called me to
set him up with a broker
to help get him a place.
There wasn't this hatred.
So they'll joke, oh we're frenemies.
It's all an act.
You know, they gotta play
their role, I get it.
You know what I mean?
It's all sort of an act.
We see each other at a cigar
club I go to occasionally
and we'll sit there and joke around.
I know he's not on my side politically.
But that we are somehow
have been oppressing them
for dec--, it's nonsense.
We had good relations.
He'd been up in my father's
office dozens of times
throughout his career.
- Is part of that that if you
were to look at your resume,
your lifestyle, your the
son of a billionaire,
you grew up in New York.
You're sort of supposed to be a Democrat.
- 100%, I always say that I'm
an unlikely Republican, right?
I grew up in New York City,
I have a billionaire father.
I went to an Ivy League
school, all these things.
And the big part I talk about
that is sort of the lessons
I've seen throughout life.
I learned about sort of
that socialist movement
especially as I see the
Democrat party going really
towards welcoming sort of
socialism, communist ideals.
It's no longer a fringe
element of the party,
it's literally the leading
people are like hey,
we're vacationing in the Soviet
Union, this is wonderful.
- If only someone had
been talking about this
for the last three years.
- Exactly well that was
one of the big reasons
to write the book which
is like I hate watching
these people that talk
about the great ideals
of socialism who have never
actually lived under it.
Again I've got to caveat everything.
I'm the son of a rich
guy (mumbles), I get it.
But my mother escaped
Communist Czechoslovakia.
You know, I had a
grandfather, a grandmother
that lived under all of that nonsense.
And I had the good fortune
of them recognizing
the blessings that we
have here in this country.
So they, from a young age
I spoke Czech fluently.
My grandfather would be
like hey, he's got to see
the other side.
You have it really good here.
Just to never take anything for granted.
Just to never have that.
So he would take me over
there starting at like
the age of five for four
to six weeks every summer.
I had friends over there.
I've waiting in those bread lines, Dave.
I can assure you there's
nothing less glamorous
than an empty supermarket.
This wasn't like a helicopter generation.
I may have been five or six.
You're going to the corner
store and waiting for bread.
I've done that.
I saw as a kid, I'd be
like why is my grandmother
not in my parents wedding picture?
It was like my grandfather.
Well they let him out of the
country to walk his daughter
down the aisle, but they
wouldn't let the wife
for fear that they would defect.
What kind of system
doesn't let people leave
because they know they ain't coming back?
So I've experienced these things.
To see them pushed as
mainstream thought now
it's really scary.
I remember that my first memory of fear
that I talk about in the
book was going over there
the first time.
I was wearing like, it was pretty cool
because it was the 80s.
I was wearing a blue jean
jacket with the stars
and stripes on it.
It was kind of 80s.
- [Dave] Yeah, Rocky.
- I got pulled out of
the line by a customs guy
in a military thing with
an AK over his shoulder.
He started questioning me.
Like was I there to
preach the great aspects
of capitalism?
I'm like dude, I'm five years old.
And not like one of today's five year olds
who are much more woke.
They're asking about
nuclear proliferation.
You see this on Twitter all the time.
My two-and-a-half year old
asking me about the dangers
of nuclear proliferation
in the Korean peninsula
and its effect on macroeconomics.
No, I was five.
- It's incredible it always
happens to those blue check--.
- It's always the blue check mark kids.
They're really woke, and
I'm like it's amazing
how it just fits into the byline of today.
- None of your kids have
asked you about string theory?
- No they haven't, they haven't.
Hard to believe, I guess
they're just not that smart.
It's a shame.
I was really hoping they
would be Ph.D's at four.
- You've got to get them
to a more elite school.
That's the problem.
- I know, it's a shame.
So I've seen that stuff, I've lived it.
My 93-year old grandmother is still alive.
And I always say I'll get
the call from her in tears.
Now this is not your typical
93-year old grandmother.
I mean this is someone who
grew up in Czechoslovakia,
spent two years hiding in
the basement of her farmhouse
from the Nazis.
The real fascists, not the
nonsense that we see today.
It's okay, they can be fascists
and they can beat the hell
out of people who are right
wing conservative people.
That's not a problem.
There's a tacit acceptance
of that in today's media.
But God forbid you put
up a meme about someone
attacking the media,
I mean that's outrage,
that's front page news.
- Brian Stelter is going
to seethe in his chair.
- A billboard of someone
choking Donald Trump
in Times Square, that's no problem.
But if you put a cartoon,
CNN like Tom and Jerry thing,
oh my good.
- Didn't your dad almost
choke the dog in that picture?
It looked like the dog
was gonna be choked.
- Well the fact that the
New York Times literally
called the White House
to fact check a meme
just goes to show you
how deranged they are.
- So you don't have a dog medal?
(both men speaking at once)
- The medal had a paw.
This wasn't exactly the Medal of Honor,
but the fact that they're fact checking it
shows you the derangement,
the filter by which
other people are seeing their news.
But I get that call from my grandmother
'cause she's got CNN over there.
They don't have a conservative outlet
or even a moderate outlet.
And I mean she's in tears.
You can't let that happen there.
It always sounds so good on
paper, it's always so great.
Everything's free, everything's wonderful.
It's not, Don, I've lived.
I was like no no no, I
remember, I've been there.
But this is a woman
who's been through a lot
who's calling me in tears
for fear of her grandchildren
and her great-grandchildren and the life
that she knows they could
live in this country.
That her daughter got to
live that American dream.
She's worried about that
just going by the wayside.
And I'm like no no no, I get it.
I'm pushing back, I promise you.
But that it can take a woman like that
who's been through it all, who's seen it,
who's lived it and drive her to tears
goes to show you.
I said listen you've watched the debates.
I mean you can find a Democrat
that can say anything.
I mean there's some really looney shit
that they'll run with.
- Biden wants to send
men to women's prison
if they want to go to a women's prison.
- They want to do it,
seems totally reasonable.
Elizabeth Warren thinks
a $52 trillion bill,
which is 90% of U.S.,
is like a wonderful plan
while eliminating private insurance.
AOC thinks that $93 trillion
for the Green New Deal
to prevent cows from farting
and eliminate air travel,
that that's gonna
magically pay for itself.
And it's also gonna fund
people who are just not willing
to work even if they're able to work.
And that they don't find a
problem with that distinction,
this is not normal shit.
- They said that part was a mistake.
- Except it was in the plan, right?
Except it was in the
plan they original put.
And the whole thing's a
mistake, but minor details.
And that's what it is.
I mean it's absolutely nuts.
So when I see that it's
like we've got to combat
this stuff.
- All right so let's talk a little bit
about the way your dad has sort of evolved
over the years.
Because your pin tweet is him on Oprah.
What is it, like 1986 or something?
- It's like '86, literally talking.
I mean he is the most
consistent politician
in probably American history.
- So it's pretty incredible.
He's talking about our bad trade deals.
Now this is 33, roughly 33 years.
He's talking about out bad trade deals.
But what struck me
about it isn't just that
the things he was talking about then
are the things that
are still relevant now.
But there's clearly a
change in his demeanor now.
He's much more gruff now.
Do you think that's
just 33 years of trying
to get through the system and now,
because he comes off
as very soft actually.
It's hard for people to understand.
- Yeah, I think it's a combination.
It's probably not trying
to get through the system.
It's more like talking about it a lot,
hoping someone's gonna do something.
Hoping someone else will do something.
You know, you can throw
sidelines for so long
but what's great about
Trump is hey, he's a man.
He's gonna step up and get in the game.
He's like I can't just talk
smack from the sidelines.
I actually have to get in the game now.
And that's what it was.
You saw it in '86, and he was right then,
and he's right now.
He's sick of politicians that you and I
wouldn't let negotiate a car lease.
No, but the reality is
half of our political,
they're making trillion
dollar decisions, Dave.
In some cases $93 trillion
decisions, or trying to,
that our kids are going to be beholden to,
our grandkids are going to be beholden to.
These are people who have
done nothing in their lives.
They've never signed
the front of a paycheck.
They've never had someone's livelihood,
their family's well-being
dependent on their success.
- I'm running a bigger
payroll here in my house
than most of them.
- Than 90% of the politicians out there.
So you have John Carey
negotiating against Iran.
Like what has John Carey
negotiated in his life?
Nothing.
- Do you think there's
any risk in having a more
business sense to the government?
Or do you think that's perfectly clear?
- I think hey just look at the proof.
I think there was incredible
risk in not having any of it
for the last 50 years.
Look at what it's gotten us.
So now you see it every day.
My father will talk
about these things like
well they're building
the new Air Force One.
So he calls Boeing and will be like
how are you building a plane?
Two planes for this much?
Take a billion dollars off.
Okay, he's like what?
Wait, well why didn't you?
Well no one had ever asked us before.
Yeah, we can do that.
We want to keep good re--.
Like no one had even thought
about trying to save money.
He talks about it with
some other things he's done
with the aircraft
carriers and the systems.
It's like well we upgraded the systems
but it's not really better,
it costs a lot more,
it's harder to maintain
and if something goes wrong
when we're in the middle
of the South China Sea
we've got to bring in
15 engineers from MIT
to try to fix the catapult.
So no one's even thought
to ask these questions.
For him it was a five-minute phone call
to save a billion dollars.
That alone is more than
pretty much all of these
politicians have done
in their entire careers
because no one's even
bothered to ask the question.
They're just, well here's the price.
Oh good that's the price,
why would we question that?
- Isn't that the part of
government you have to spend
that money one year because
otherwise they're just
gonna cut you?
- Otherwise they cut your budget.
- But that's why the
deficit keeps going up.
- It keeps going up because
everyone wants more power.
More power's in having more money
and having a higher budget.
So you fix things that don't need fixing.
You create problems that don't exist
to justify an existence that is asinine.
It's why government keeps
growing at the level
that it is and it's
centralized around D.C.,
usually far away from the
things they're supposed
to be managing and running
with people who have no idea
what's actually going on.
So I think Trump,
there's all the Americans
being fed up by actually seeing that.
I mean Americans, despite the
media's portrayal of them,
they get it.
They're so much more onto
this system than anyone.
It's why you have Trump.
They're sick of just being
looked over, forgotten.
America's number one export
as far as I'm concerned
for the last 50 years has
been the American Dream.
We have sent that dream to
countries that hate our guts.
They hate our values,
they hate our freedoms,
they hate everything about us.
That's been our big export
because of stupid practices
by guys that have no
idea what they're doing
up against people that
are literally experts
in their fields.
Got Ph.D's in this stuff
and they're laughing
their ass off for years that
America's just giving it up.
We've giving up 200 years
of hegemony that we've had
to appease people that hate our guts.
And Trump's the counter response to that.
It's why you see China's
trade, oh yeah we really
want to negotiate against Trump.
And the media, oh they
really love negotiat--.
Guys, maybe they're just
saying that because they know
you'll bite hook, line, and sinker.
'Cause in all fairness who
else has even questioned
the nonsense that they've been doing?
They hate Trump because
Trump's finally pushed back
after decades of them sucking us dry.
Sucking our jobs out, sucking out money,
just destroying our middle class.
Now someone's pushing back.
- Is that the crazy part
that we're so trained
not to think about how the
system actually works over time
that then when someone
comes in and says things.
So like NATO, for example,
when your dad was like
well some of these countries
are gonna have to pay
their fair share.
- Oh my God, he's destroying them.
The president of NATO is actually come up
like hey listen, this was no fan of Trump.
Well NATO has raised
an extra, what was it?
Like $100 billion because
if you say you're gonna take
two percent, three percent, four percent
of your GDP and put it towards
defending yourself, do it.
Do it, it's not rocket sci--.
This was a pact before Trump,
but no one bothered to
say hey guys come on.
You owe this money.
They just said okay.
Watching Germany--
- What do you think our
leaders were actually doing?
- Nothing, they don't
care, it's not their money.
It's other people's
money, it doesn't matter.
It's no different than Air Force One.
Why would we ask to negotiate, who cares?
You know I'd love to get
on the board of Boeing
later on, so we're not
going to question them.
We're not going to ask them to do better.
Maybe they'll give me a
really lucrative position
when I'm out of government.
I watched last year the
outrage that the media had.
Germany's really upset
that Trump is telling them
they've gotta pay or we're
not gonna defend them.
They were literally upset
that Trump is saying
pay up your fair share.
They're meanwhile complaining
that we're not going
to defend then against Russians
while they're giving them
billions of dollars a year
combing for Russian oil.
So you want us to defend
you against Russia
while you're giving
them more money than God
in a pipeline natural gas deal.
You could be taking
that from us, too guys.
The hypocrisy of the thing.
Germany outraged about, it's nonsense.
Trump's calling all of these people.
He's calling all of their
bluffs and no one has
in decades.
- So with the calling of
the bluffs so that sort of
brings us back to the Ukraine situation
because it seems to me, stop
me if you think I'm nuts here.
But it seems to me that
if Donald Trump, Jr.,
was getting about 85 grand a month to work
for a company in a
foreign land who he didn't
have any expertise in doing what they do.
- In a language I didn't speak.
In a business I know nothing about.
- I think you see where
I'm going with this.
What's going on here?
- That's the hypocrisy.
- We're talking about Hunter Biden.
- Of course, the media loves to do this.
They go oh, Donald Trump,
Jr. attacked Hunter Biden.
I go yeah.
Donald Trump, Jr., he's so not self-aware.
I was like no no no, I get it.
I'm the son of a rich guy,
I've gotten a big part.
I've said it on Hannity a couple times.
I didn't give the three-minute disclaimer
the second time I was
on so they're like oh,
he doesn't get that he's also benefiting.
I go no no, I've benefited
from my father's last name.
I share his name, I get that.
I'm not pretending that hasn't happened.
- But also aren't you proud of that?
- 100%.
- We have this fear of success here.
- But Dave, the difference
between me and Hunter Biden
is I did that through the
business that he built up
as a capitalist.
If he wanted to give me a billion dollars
I could put it on pound
floor, light it on fire
and that's our prerogative.
I mean the difference is I didn't do it
through my daddy's taxpayer-funded office.
Magically become an
international businessman.
When we won, before he even
took the presidency we said
we are not going to do new foreign deals.
And we had deals, buildings were building
and we can't just pull out.
We have a contractual obligation.
We said we will not, that was
a big part of my business.
That's why I'm so involved in politics
because that's what I did.
I have a lot more free
time now so it's like hey,
I'll get involved with
this and fight for what
I believe in.
That's why I wrote a book.
But the false equivalency of
being like well how are you
different than Hunter Biden?
How am I different?
I was an international
businessman for the last 15 years.
We stopped doing those deals
just so they could have
no impropriety story.
Hunter Biden magically becomes
an international businessman,
gets on the board of an energy company.
He knows nothing about energy,
he has no track record.
And is making $83,000
a month in the Ukraine
where his father's in charge.
Media, no no no, that's off limits.
I wasn't off limits for
two-and-a-half years.
Kids are off limits.
Barron Trump's not off
limits, they hit him.
Tiffany Trump who's in
law school, did nothing,
just a nice kid going to
school, she's not off limits.
I wasn't off limits when they
spent two-and-a-half years
trying to throw me in jail for treason
for taking a 20-minute
unsolicited meeting.
Hunter Biden's off limits
for a shady board seat
in a corrupt company?
He's off limits when he take 1.5 billion
from the Chinese government.
Not like a Chinese investor,
from the Chinese government
after traveling there on Air
Force Two with his father?
What would the media do if
Donald Trump, Jr., did that?
- But they said they didn't talk about it.
- Obviously they didn't
mention the business.
They knew nothing about it
when they're playing golf together?
I just say do the other thing.
How about this?
Let's go earlier in life.
Hunter Biden gets a great job
at MBNA right out of school.
Happens to be the largest
bank and the largest employer
in the state of Delaware
where Joe is the senator
signing favorable tax legislation.
He's a brilliant guy, he's a
brilliant guy so he manages
to rise through the ranks
there faster than anyone.
Obviously totally a coincidence.
He then gets a board seat on Amtrak at 27.
Huge, he's a lover of trains.
He's a lover of trains obviously, Dave.
I mean that's why he got it.
Nothing to do with daddy
controlling the purse strings.
No no no, that's off limits.
I haven't talked much
about it because honestly
it's not even worth it.
But you get frustrated enough
'cause they have to attack
my personal life, everything about it.
What would happen if Donald
Trump, Jr., got thrown
out of the Navy Reserve
in two weeks for doing
a little of the yayo?
Testing positive for cocaine, you think
they'd have a prob--?
You think they'd give me the pass?
People don't even hear about that.
Turning in a rental car with a crack pipe
and all of these things.
The media would have a field
day, so much so I almost
should go do it because
if when they catch it.
- [Dave] You've got a
real death wish, man.
- The aneurysm that they
would have, no no no,
it would be good for us
because it would solve
the fake news media problem.
Their heads would explode with outrage
that there'd be none left
and we could get back
to a reasonable discourse.
So they try to do this false equivalency
of what's the difference.
I go that's the difference.
Hunter Biden made millions of dollars
through his father's
taxpayer-funded office,
has all this other shade in the past
and he's totally off limits.
But you had no problem with
half of Congress saying
that I literally committed treason,
a crime punishable by death,
for taking a 20-minute
unsolicited meeting.
But Hillary Clinton can
go out, pay foreign agents
to go collect dirt.
Take that dirt through the
DNC, leak it to the FBI.
The FBI then leaks it back to the press.
The press writes their
outrage story which the FBI
then uses as the basis of an investigation
of individuals on a
campaign for the President
of the United States which
started the whole Muller hoax.
I mean where's the outrage?
Not even the outrage, where's the story?
You've got a couple guys,
Sarah Carter, Sean Hannity,
Gregg Jarrett, a couple
of guys pointing out.
But you'd think that
this would be big news.
If you're a journalist
this is kind of a big deal.
This is a legitimate coup
and they're just like
we have nothing to see here.
There's nothing going on here, guys.
We're just gonna pretend
this never happened
because it goes against what
they would like to happen.
It goes against the DNC talkers.
It goes against that media narrative.
And since they've made
that cognizant decision
to be the marketing wing of
the DNC we should actually
look into them for
campaign finance violations
because they're just literally
contributing millions
and billions of free marketing to the DNC
covering for their bullshit.
- So who, in the course of all of this,
I hear you on all of this.
Who, in the course of all
this, do you and I guess
by extension your dad,
actually take counsel from?
I remember during the
Michael Cohen testimony
it was one of the first
moments when I was like
this Russia thing is complete nonsense.
But the reason wasn't because
of anything that he said.
It was because you were live tweeting it.
And I was like if this guy
is guilty, meaning you.
If you were guilty of
anything your lawyers
or everyone you know
would be locking you up
and putting you in a room
and taking your phone.
Because you were live
tweeting it so freely.
- It was funny, my lawyer's
like you can't do that.
Anything you say.
I'm like I don't care, I'm right.
I don't care.
This is bullshit and I'm gonna say it.
So I literally had that conversation.
I sat down with my lawyers numerous.
I go, you guys are making
one critical mistake.
If I sit down, if I just sit
in the corner and curl up
in a ball and die, or cry sucking my thumb
in the fetal position
that's what they want.
You think they're gonna
go any lighter on me?
They're not.
Adam Schiff was on TV every
day saying I committed treason.
He's seen evidence, to the entire country.
He's seen evidence of treason
and collusion and all.
I still haven't seen it.
You'd think if he's
seen it no one else has.
Maybe it's time to drop it by now.
It wasn't in the Muller report.
So I'm saying I'm just
not gonna do it, man.
I'm not gonna just sit back.
I get where you're going
from a legal strategy.
I'm not naive to that,
it's not that I'm stupid.
- I'm not saying that it
was the right thing to do.
I'm just saying.
- I get where they're saying.
I go, I just don't care and
honestly at the end of it
they go you know what, you were right.
You needed to push back
because you could see it.
I'm in closed door
testimony with the House
Intelligence Committee right.
And I come back, I'm out of
this thing after nine hours
or so of testimony.
I get out at seven o'clock at
night and I look at Twitter
and CNN, at 11:59, Donald
Trump, Jr., was saying this.
I go, Jesus Christ I mean
Adam Schiff is taking
bathroom breaks and
leaking this stuff to--
- [Dave] Closed door, closed door?
- Closed door, it was
supposed to be totally.
And I got back, I'm looking
back seven hours in advance.
Every time we took a bathroom break CNN
is breaking this stuff.
I mean three of their big
bombshells had to do with me.
Now they were all wrong,
they were all false.
One of them was the WikiLeaks.
Some random dude literally
DM'ed me or sent me an email.
Like have you seen this?
It was like whatever, let's
call it June 14th right?
They leaked the stuff to CNN
and I'm looking at the date stamp.
Do you have comments on that?
It was June fourth.
I'm like holy shit they
deleted the one in 14, right?
So the 14, you delete
the one, it becomes four.
So the thing broke on like June 10th
or whatever it was, right?
So it looks like I had this
information from some random.
It's a Trump donor, he
donated like 25 bucks
and somehow spammed our email.
So actually hit my email so it got there.
I didn't respond, I didn't,
but it looked like them
from the leaked email I
had it six days before
rather than four days after
the rest of the freakin' world.
Not different than sort of
me outing the whistleblower
after it's been out there
in the public for four days.
I'm just like oh my God, bombshell,
Donald Trump, Jr., had it.
I'm like here's the
tweets, here's the emails.
How come where the only ones
being transparent, Dave.
(both speaking at once)
- An apology, did you ever get a call
somebody in the media?
- Not even a retraction on some of these.
Michael Cohen was there.
When Donald Trump, Jr., no
his lawyer pulled that one.
His lawyer pulled it back
because they got it wrong
and they're the guys leaking it.
It's so asinine.
Then they question about it.
Now there was no
questioning about him then
literally perjuring himself I think it was
eight or nine times.
(mumbles) I'm like nope, didn't happen.
Check XYZ.
I mean Jim Jordan, some
of them called it out.
They sent the thing back to the DOJ.
Be like, hey what about this?
Nothing, we're not playing the same game
and that's the problem.
I mean there are some
Republicans that are doing it.
There are some that
are learning from Trump
because Trump has taught
conservatives hey,
you can fight back.
You don't just have to lose
'cause they want you to.
You don't just have to give
up because they're going
to write a bad story about you.
But what the problem is that
mentality is still there.
Like okay well you know, we're leave this.
They would never give us that
same benefit of the doubt.
I say hey, we can all play t-ball
or we can all play hardball.
But we've gotta be playing
the same game and we're not.
- Do you ever fear that
that, or does your dad
ever fear that that
game, so I agree with you
on the premise that we
had to break this thing
so that with could start
resetting the system
in a sensible way.
But the game of sort
of constant destruction
one way or another.
That's dangerous, ultimately.
- It is, by the way I'd
love to break that game.
But they're not gonna do it.
You know what I mean?
They have to work with
us a little bit on that.
I mean the perfect example, the USMCA,
the renegotiation of NAFTA.
Everyone said it couldn't be done.
It was the worst trade deal
in the history of trade deals.
Everyone will admit that.
My father, against all odds,
renegotiated with Mexico
and Canada that would
bring over 100,000 jobs
back to this country.
Manufacturing jobs where we need it.
It's been sitting on Nancy's
desk for nine months.
This will pass with flying colors.
She won't even bring it to the vote
because although it would
be good for Americans,
it would give Trump another win.
Okay he's already got the economic wins.
But it would give him another
win and we can't do that.
It would pass, Dave, you could
do this bill in 30 seconds
'cause there's probably not a Democrat
that would vote against this thing.
It would pass with flying colors.
But you know what?
By giving Trump a win it
would be better for them
to keep more jobs out of the country,
to do that so they can resist.
You need a little bit--, how about working
on an infrastructure plan
that would do the same
and it's well needed?
How come there's no outrage
that Trump was the guy
that got prison reform done?
Where was Obama?
I mean they have no
problem letting Joe Biden
running around.
His primary campaign thing
is government has failed you.
I'm like no shit Joe,
I'm with you on this one.
If I've been in the Senate for 30 years
and in big government for 50
legit, not like hyperbole,
for actually 50 years dude,
maybe you're part of the problem.
And that is the game that
is being played right now.
It's a shame.
Trump is probably the
only guy that can do that.
But you need a little bit
of give from the other side.
Hey, I think if anyone knows him,
he's actually a pragmatist.
Prison reform ain't exactly
a conservative talking point.
You know what it is, Dave?
It was the right thing to do.
It's not gonna win him voters in his base.
He probably won't even get much credit
from the people who are
going to benefit much from it
because I mean the
communities where they live
the general sentiment is to Democrat.
But it was the right thing
to do so he did it anyway.
I'd love to see some of that sentiment
from the other side.
That doesn't exist there,
certainly not today
and certainly not with Trump.
- I hear ya man, and
believe me, I've been trying
to clean up what was my side.
I can't honestly say it's my side anymore.
But I've been trying, ya know?
- Probably no one quite so
tolerant as someone out there
preaching tolerance.
- So you mentioned sort
of what's happening
with some of the minority
communities before.
What do you make of
what's going on right now
with the Black community?
Because I do sense that through Candace
and through Kanye West
now, and what was it
that your dad did just this week?
Was it the Black Leadership Summit?
Or it was another one of these?
(both mean speaking at once)
- But he's bringing
people to the White House,
he's giving them a platform.
He did things that were unprecedented
for a lot of the minority communities.
We have all-time low, all-time low
African American unemployment,
all-time low Hispanic
unemployment, all-time low female,
all-time high business startups.
African American community,
Hispanic community, female.
Again, if Obama did this
everyone would be give him
the credit.
The problem is I do
think that people get it.
I do think that people see it but man,
they are like even so many of the Trump,
they're like we get it,
we see it but we can't
say anything about it
because we'll get destroyed.
I mean getting the
information down to the people
is hard because yeah, the
DNC controls the churches.
They control the community leaders,
they control all of this thing.
They've had a stranglehold on that.
So even if it's happening,
getting the information down
to the voter is hard
'cause it's going through
so many levels of nonsense.
This didn't happen, and
you've got so much outrage
where they're still pushing.
But I do think that the American voter,
the regular guy, I give
him so much more credit.
Whether that's a Trump supporter,
whether it's the minority
community I give them
so much more credit.
The example I love to use
is back in June we launched
the 2020 campaign in Orlando, in Florida.
It was awesome.
47,000 people something
showed up in an arena
that holds 25.
They stood out in the rain for two days.
Thunderstorms, (mumbles) how
many people are gonna still
be here after the thunderstorm?
I was a little worried.
Not one person left, Dave, it was awesome.
I got to introduce the VP
who introduced the President.
It was right after the
Muller hoax was exposed
and it was like Robert Muller testimony.
It was like Mr. Muller, I'm tweeting like
have you actually read the Muller report?
He had no clue what's going on.
They just used him because
he was above reproach.
He was a former decorated
Marine and the leader
of the FBI.
So Trump can't attack him.
- It's not my purview.
That was his line over and over.
- The genesis of it all,
you spent $40 million
in three years and you
have no idea what it is?
You realize that he
was just a pawn, right?
You magically selected 19 leftist donors
to be the objective
arbiters of this thing?
Come on, but we're there and
it was this incredible rally.
It was so warm it was just
insane, it was awesome.
And I get back out and 20 minutes later
I'm watching TV.
Did you see those people, ugh.
They're out there in their flip flops.
That must be their formal attire.
(laughing)
It was disgusting, man.
And you saw the level of
disdain, the level of hatred
that the liberal elite and the media,
largely one and the
same for the most part,
has for just hardworking people.
They think it's racist for those people
to want to live their American dream.
They are terrible people, Dave,
for wanting their tax
dollars to be spent on them,
maybe their children again
rather than some country
that hates your freedom,
values, your religion,
every aspect about you.
What civilization would never take care
of their people first?
I'm all for helping the world.
Frankly, no country does more
from a charity perspective
than the United States of America.
But maybe we take care
of our own problems.
You're not one of the -ists:
misogynists, terrorists,
racists, whatever it is for maybe saying
why don't we take care of our veterans
before some guy that can't stand us?
Why don't we take care
of our education system
when we're number 28 in the
world behind a long list
of third world countries
that are crushing us
and we're spending 10x per capita?
Why don't we fix those
problems first with our t--.
You're not a bad person for wanting that.
And when I saw that disdain it's just like
that's some of the stuff that triggers me.
I too am not above being triggered
even if I wrote the book about it.
It's that nonsense that you're just like
how do you get through that filter?
93% of the media about Trump is negative
despite unprecedented success.
There's literally not an economic metric
where we are not better
off today than we were
under Obama, but you don't hear about it.
The Democrat debates, how do
we take Trump's Twitter away?
Why don't we address China?
They literally didn't talk about China.
Joe Biden says it's not a problem.
Now I believe him because
his son's on the payroll
for a billion five.
I get it, but the others don't believe
it's a problem either?
Are we out of our minds?
- So with all that in mind
and talking about the filter
because you're talking about the way
the mainstream media
operates, and then the filter.
We're doing this on YouTube.
I know you've talked a lot about--
- [Donald] Are we still on air?
- Tech censorship, I don't
know if we're still on air.
I may have to say the
guy's name at the end.
I've been debating it this
whole time because it seems
like if we don't say it in a way,
I'm not going to ask you to say it.
But it sort of seems like if we don't
then it's doing the reverse
of what you're saying there.
- I hate, I don't like
to cave to anything.
Again if that was my demeanor I wouldn't.
But there are times where you're like man
it's a Catch-22.
You don't even want to go
there because you don't
want to give that person the platform
because you know what the media will do
in manipulating it.
So I use, I talk a lot
about tech censorship
in the book because I've
been calling it out.
I mean we've had
discussions three years ago.
Not even on air, just
what do you do about this?
The example I use in the book,
although there's numerous
was I got taken down off
of Instagram for a post
I didn't know was "hate speech."
I was one of the first sort
of blue check mark guys
to be able to be like guys
like I get that you're running
with this Jussie Smollett thing.
And if it happened fry these guys.
There's no fuckin' place for
that anywhere in this country.
Not even a little bit.
But within 30 seconds it's on
every mainstream talk show.
Oh my God, this obviously happened.
I go guys, has anyone asked the question?
Do you really think a
really rich actor in Chicago
on the coldest night of
the year is going out
at two in the morning to
satisfy his craving for Subway?
I don't know, it seems a bit odd.
Do you really think that
two white supremacists
walking around downtown Chicago.
- [Dave] Don't forget the hats.
- In MAGA hats with a bucket of bleach
and a noose made of twine.
Like you think they're
really roaming the streets
of down--?
You think they live for
more than 15 to 20 seconds
without getting shot?
You really think they
magically thought that this guy
would be going out at that same time?
I mean they really had a premonition here.
I'm like has anyone asked this question
of it just sounds a
little bit too obvious?
Jussie may be a good actor,
but he ain't a good writer.
- [Dave] He's not a great actor either.
- He's not a great actor but by the way,
do you really think
these white supremacists
were watching Empire?
(both speaking at the same time)
If you're a white
supremacist watching Empire,
I'm like I don't know it doesn't seem like
it really caters to that audience.
Like you really know who this guy is?
So I asked the question.
I got taken down for hate
speech and this and that
and the other.
And I put it right back up.
I'd be like am I not allowed
to ask a question anymore?
And it was interesting
because I actually checked
my DM's, not the people
I follow but I'll just
scroll through and see
what people are saying.
And the amount of people,
Dave, that took time,
and I've done this a
couple times when I've
called them out or been
de-platformed where I see
I had 57 million impressions
this week, zero new followers.
Like hey, Instagram what's going on here?
Twitter, what are you doing?
(both men speaking at once)
And then the next day
it's back up to normal.
Yeah you feel it, but
someone has to call them out.
Again I'm just one, I'm that
guy that's willing to do it.
I'm the son of the President.
We run a multi-billion dollar business.
I've got a lot to lose
if I get this wrong.
But someone has to have the
balls to actually be like
I just want to ask the question.
And the amount of people though, Dave,
that reached out to me they're
writing paragraphs to my DM.
It was like I realize this
is a one in a billion chance
that you're even gonna see this thing.
But they take paragraphs, here's a photo.
They're taking video of
their phones DM'ing it to me.
Here's me trying to like your tweet.
And I don't mean some
political outrage tweet
or an Instagram post.
Here's the heart, lights
up, gone, here's the heart.
Kimberly, my girlfriend, she's
like I've had to follow you
four times this week.
I'm like, was I that bad last
night, did you unfollow me?
She can get a little spicy.
Did you unfollow me because you're mad?
She's like no Don.
But they're reaching out and
saying I've been locked out
of my account for 24
hours for liking a post
which was your dad's post of
him with his grandchildren.
Not even the political stuff.
And you see it and it's
like one after the--,
and thousands and thousands so I'm saying.
- All right so going on the
assumption that everyone
watching this believes this.
The Google leaker basically
said that my channel
is one of the one's being targeted.
So I hear you, right?
So then I think a lot of
people, conservatives are saying
then why doesn't the
government get involved?
I have my own thoughts on it.
- I think they have to.
I mean these monopolies again.
The problem is this, the conservative side
has always done the free
market, it's free market.
No, it's not because what
they don't talk about
is those same platforms
get so much protections
from the government in terms
of some of the hate speech.
They basically get an insurance
policy from the government.
Once you're getting that policy,
once you're getting those
benefits from the government
you can no longer say
well I'll listen to you
but not you.
So they're doing in and
the reality is I think
until I started getting vocal and calling
some of these guys, now
there are guys doing it.
Kevin McCarthy's calling
it out in the House.
Josh Holly's doing a good job
calling it out in the Senate.
But the reality is
honestly most conservatives
didn't even realize that this is an issue.
And as I travel the
country and talk to guys
in the base, it's probably like
a top three issue for them.
They're saying if they can do it,
they use the example, if they can do it
to Donald Trump, Jr. with
millions of followers,
if they can do it to the
President of the United States
I mean you saw the
example I used last week.
It was like Donald Trump,
Jr., searching my handle
in Instagram.
Donald J. Trump, Jr., pretty specific.
Two million followers and I share the name
of the President.
Him and I did not show
up in the first six pages
of the scroll.
- [Dave] Just fake accounts, basically.
- Don Trump QPX underscore
7642 with one follower
and two posts shows up in
page one, and the President--
- He's funny though,
he's funny, good memes.
- He's pretty good, he's pretty good.
He's gonna be the next
general in the meme wars.
And it shows you.
So those guys are finally
starting to get it.
But it wasn't even on their radar.
So it's my job and your
job to be vocal about it.
To call out that hypocrisy.
- But are you worry
though that when you see
these guys, all the progressives
go after Zuckerberg,
let's say, and I'm no
great fan of Zuckerberg.
But basically what I
watched in that hearing
a couple weeks ago was AOC and Pressley
and the rest of them,
they were basically saying
we can't control speech
because it's against the First Amendment.
So we're going to force you to do it.
- [Donald] It's not just Zuckerberg.
- Isn't that the fear though?
- 100%, and it's not just Zuckerberg.
The problem is this, the
pervasive mentality over
in Silicon Valley.
So he may have 20,000 people
that all agree with AOC.
And they're the ones actually
sitting there probably.
He may not even know
what the hell is going on
because you have an army of
people that all feel one way.
That all believe free speech
for me but not for thee.
That all will more than
happily tweet the algorithms.
I don't even know how much he knows.
But you watch them hey,
he's not exactly right wing.
And they're canceling him
for not being crazy enough
to satisfy their goals.
So the reality is we've
got to be out there.
We've got to call them out
and we've got to hold them to task.
We can just say okay well I don't want
a mean tweet from AOC.
Who cares?
- But is the fear that
then you give the power
to the government and now,
let's say your dad loses
and now congratulations,
you've handed the power
to Elizabeth Warren who
would be more than happy--
(both men speaking at once)
- That's the reality and that's why
some of the gun control argument you see
well if someone believes
red flag laws make sense,
whether I agree with them or
not it's almost irrelevant.
You see within seconds Ben
Shapiro put up the thing,
if someone came to my door--,
I mean he has a sarcastic
thing about I'd bring a gun.
And Eric Swallow, a congre--,
this is why we need it.
He shouldn't be able to ha--.
I'm like Jesus Christ, you
take a pretty reasonable guy,
not exactly an alt-right
guy though he's been painted
as a Nazi even though
he's Orthodox Jewish.
You're gonna say that
that guy shouldn't be able
to exercise his Second Amendment?
You can't trust the left
because you know immediately
they will weaponize these things.
But there does need to be a dialogue.
There does need to be checks and balances
because you see that
censorship and you see hey,
Trump utilized social more effectively
than any human being in history in 2016.
And you know what they're doing.
It's a dry run for 2020.
(both men speaking at once)
But they're gonna minimize his reach,
they're gonna minimize who gets to see it,
who gets to follow.
Again if I have people,
dozens a day saying,
Don, I'm magically not
following you but I am following
seven left-wing media
sites that I didn't ever
try to follow, that I
never even looked at.
They're just appearing in my
feed not as sponsored links.
But I'm looking, I'm saying
I never followed them
but now I am.
You can see it's a dry
run to prevent them,
to prevent him, to prevent the campaign,
to prevent other conservatives
to be able to get
their message to people who need it.
Donald Trump played monkey
in the middle with the media.
He said I'm just gonna go
right over your filter,
right over your heads and bring my message
right to the people.
And they're like how can we limit that?
We may not be able to limit in entirely,
but how can we limit it?
- So then how is this not gonna happen?
I hear you, I agree.
- I'm gonna keep being vocal about it.
I'm gonna keep holding
Congress on both sides to task.
If they're sitting on
there floundering a win
I'll call them out on it.
Like I said, I'm not in
this business right now
in the long run.
I don't care, I'm just gonna call out.
Hey I've done it to other
conservatives, you've seen that.
Hey like I see you on Hannity
you're complaining about XYZ,
but I don't actually see
you doing anything about it.
There's one thing sort
of pandering to a base.
There's one thing sort of
talking to those people.
But talk is talk, action is action.
And they're two very different things.
So you sort of make it seem
like there's action here
but you're not doing shit.
I'll hold those guys
to task even if they're
theoretically on our side.
- All right, I've got one more for ya,
because I know you've got a busy day today
and we're already over.
But first off I just want to quickly say,
because I meant to say it at the beginning
that we did not discuss
any of this beforehand
what we were gonna do.
Your guys did not ask me don't say this
or talk about this.
(both men speaking at once)
You literally walked in,
you were like let's roll.
And I just think it's important.
- I don't put preconditions
on stuff like this.
Again there are people
I definitely don't want
to give a platform to
because I know what the media
will then do with that.
So there's always a Catch-22.
But no, the reality is--
- [Dave] And now I'm gonna prove it.
- There's nothing off limits.
- I'm gonna prove it
now, you got one minute.
I mean, are you gonna
get, are you gonna run?
At some point does this
all lead to you in 2024?
- Right now the reality is this.
My only focus for the next year
is getting my father re-elected, my only.
Again unlike Hunter Biden,
I'm walking away from a lot
of our business.
We did that naturally,
created an opening for me.
I see what's going on, I'm
the father of five young kids.
I see the results.
I want them to grow up in an
America that we recognize.
A lot of people have done it, I get that.
Trump 2020, Trump 2024 too, man.
And the book signings I heard
that 2,000 times yesterday,
no exaggeration.
Honestly there's no greater
compliment from those people
who believe that, who like
perhaps what I'm doing or saying.
The reality is this, I have no aspirations
beyond 2020 right now.
That doesn't mean that doesn't change.
I'm certainly not gonna rule it out.
I do enjoy the game, I do enjoy the game.
But I don't know that I'd
like the day job right now.
I've gotta know I want
that aspect of it, too.
Now it is fascinating, it is
incredible to see these people.
And again I'm probably
much more comfortable,
and you've seen that in the
Midwest, in the Rust Belt
than I am in the New York
City rubber chicken dinner
charity circuit B.S.
I don't do it 'cause I am a real hunter.
I am a competitive shooter.
But it sounds crazy because
again I know where I'm from,
I know who I am, I know
I'm the yada yada yada,
when they try to own me for that.
But the reality is I
have so many of those,
that's where I choose to spend my time.
That's where my real friends are.
So I hear that a lot.
But my biggest thing is making
sure you get four more years
'cause I think you can
really change the course
of this craziness.
And every day is yet
ano--, I mean I could write
literally the addendum to this book today
in the amount of time
since this went to print.
The amount of bullshit that has happened
I'm like Jesus Chri--, I
could write like three books.
So I do like it, I do enjoy it.
I do love seeing the difference it makes.
- You're doing the hand motion right now.
(laughing)
- I may have to do the Trump cobra.
I guess that was a little Clinton-esque,
so I've got to be careful with that.
But I do enjoy it but again my
only focus right now is 2020.
Whatever happens after
that there's plenty of time
for that conversation.
I would never rule it out.
But again I like the
fight aspect of this game.
I don't know that I'd like the day job.
We'll see what happens but
it has been an awesome ride.
It has been an awesome journey.
It was awesome to be able
to put it in long form
in the book rather than just
sort of 280 characters or less
or first half of that
140 characters of less.
Because you could kind
of get your thought out.
However that's manipulated in the press
we'll leave it up to the readers to decide
if I'm truly as terrible
as everyone says I am.
But that never really mattered
to me, as we've discussed.
- Good finish and I'm pretty
sure he just said he's running.
It's at Donald J. Trump, Jr. on Twitter.
That's what they're gonna--.
- One of the guys that did that
after my convention speech,
they're like oh my God, Donald
Trummp, Jr.'s gonna run.
I was like hey I'm not gonna rule it out.
They go, he's running.
I'm like wait, because
that's cancel culture.
If 2016 I say yeah, I'm not gonna do it
and in 15 years I change
my mind, oh you're a liar.
I mean you basically committed perjury.
I mean you're obviously all this bullshit
we've been hearing for the last cu--.
So I never wanna rule it
out because I know it can
and will come back to be used against you
in the court of public opinion.
So I'm never gonna rule it out.
But that was also definitely
not the affirmative
yes it's obviously, it's in the works.
But we'll talk off the
record, just kidding.
- At Donald J. Trump, Jr. on Twitter.
- Thanks, man.